In the responsive images support course,
they tell you how to
use unicode characters.
I believe it's like fontawesome.
So you can take these icons and
link them, so
you get a Facebook icon or
a Twitter icon that you can use.
So if you want to add something special,
you can check out that course and
try to give that a shot if you want.
>> So,
this is the CSS Zen Garden web site.
As you can see here,
there's all kinds of little things
you can choose from the side.
But if we go to view all designs here,
we can see that there's just tons of
just these amazing looking pages.
Let's go to this apothecary one.
I mean like,
just really well thought out designs,
really good use of font and spacing and
page breaks and things like that.
And this is all the same CSS as,
say, this page.
Or sorry, all the same content, [LAUGH]
not CSS obviously, all the same content.
Two completely different pages,
two completely different styles, but
all of the same content and
just sort of this beautiful use of CSS.
So if you're looking for inspiration
on what you want to do with your CSS or
your style, this is a great
page to look for some ideas.
Some of it is very advanced,
so by no means do you have to
create something like this.
The people making these
tend to be like really
well-established graphic designers.
But I mean, you can just get some ideas
of some of the awesome things you
can do with CSS.
>> Can you recommend a good source
of copyright for your images?
That I do.
Look for
the word creative commons license.
A lot of people,
a lot of independent photographers,
they post free photos every day,
everywhere.
Just search for the word
creative commons license, photos.
Flickr has a whole set of great
photos that you can look on,
and there's a filter on Flickr for
creative commons license.
And if you don't want to use Flickr,
just use your favorite search engine.
And type creative commons license
images, and it will have a filter to
search by images and it will give
you all the creative commons images.
And those are all free to use, provided
that you give the author attribution.